sa vie n'était pas bon
ça veut dire quoi
d'accord
pour
88 c'est énorme je poussais
merci
vitres
[Musique]
alors la question qui se pose c'est
est-ce qu'ils ont bien fait de
communiquer sur les réseaux ce qu'il
fallait le faire comme ça j'ai demandé à
magali forcément ben oui parce qu'à
partir du moment où ils prennent cette
décision de montrer leur vie de
s'exposer etc ils ont une chaîne youtube
il montre toujours leur venue shana et
et jeu et donne donc en fait c'est
normal c'est la continuité puis quelque
part je trouve ça intéressant même pour
les gens qui à qui ça peut arriver de
voir comment ils doivent les recourants
d'avoir des informations c'était moi je
trouve pas ça si choquant que ça fait au
contraire ça peut aider effectivement
suite ça fait quelque chose ils l'ont
fait de façon relativement oui
c'était oui oui justement moi
généralement je suis pas trop télé
réalité parce que je trouve qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses superficielles tu
vois mes mais là pour le coup je trouve
ça intéressant parce que ça peut aider
des gens qui ne sont pas dans la télé
réalité qui sont pas attirés par sa
juste parce que ça peut arriver dans
toutes les familles donc par exemple moi
ça m'intéresse de savoir qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire comment est-ce qu'ils
vont le faire et comment est-ce qu'on
peut gérer ce alors que ce témoignage
parce qu'un enfant sur deux mille
peut-être atteint d'anomalies comme sa
génétique et c'est à la 11ème semaine de
grossesse qu'on peut le voir avec une
échographie plus une prise de sang et or
la peau des wikipédiens